en France il y a moi disparaissait la
petite Estelle à la sortie de l'école
depuis le travail des inspecteurs et les
moyens mis en place ont été
considérables mais aucune trace de la
fillette de 9 ans l'émotion et
l'inquiétude grandissent un peu plus
chaque jour dans le petit village de
Guermantes Yves Martinet Bruno Vignier
disparu depuis un mois aujourd'hui un
mois durant lequel les parents d'Estelle
ont tout fait tout essayé des appels à
témoins d'abord affichés partout en
France mais aussi un site internet grâce
auquel une immense chaîne de solidarité
a vu le jour malgré ses moyens toujours
rien ça fait un mois qu'on a aucune
aucune piste aucune information aucun
élément nouveau aucun élément matériel
aucune idée sur laquelle on puisse
asseoir notre action donc on est face au
vide total donc c'est ce que j'ai dit
c'est une excellente forme de torture
côté en quête les policiers ont passé
les environs au peigne fin sont des
plusieurs étangs procédés à un millier
d'auditions avant de s'intéresser à tous
les délinquants sexuels connus dans la
région 10 personnes ont été placées en
garde à vue en vain agarmante la
population encore choquée vacille entre
craintes et espoirs les gens en parlent
toujours se posent toujours beaucoup de
questions ça c'est certain mais bon
on tourne un peu en rond on a beau se
poser plein de questions on voit
vraiment pas ce qu'il y a plus pas c'est
quoi on se demande j'ai peur que ça ça
s'atténue tout doucement et qu'on
arrivait à oublier et ça faut pas
oublier
les initiatives pour retrouver Estelle
se multiplient prochainement une
association verra le jour et dans la
semaine cette affiche de 4 mètres par 3
sera placardée sur un millier de
panneaux publicitaires